[Music]
okay everybody so this is my review of
dexter new blood episode 8 unfair game
we have another short episode this week
at only 43 minutes long and this episode
had a lot of strong parts to it
but it does feel very much like
a transitional episode in the season we
only have two more after this and maybe
thinking this was going to be like a big
showdown episode it's really not it's
kind of actually
nicely setting up the bigger issues at
hand here for dexter for curtin for
having angela now really solving a lot
about dexter here which we'll get into
and setting up more again this
connection between harrison dexter
finally hits which we're also going to
get to but let's just first start with
the top of this episode i like this
moment here where dexter sleeping in the
back of the car of this henchman and
it's directly continuing where it left
off but he's having this dream of
harrison he's going like full negan here
did you hear that
he said
suck my nuts pure animal but as you can
see dexter's reaction in the dream on
his face this isn't what dexter wants
for harrison this is tied up really well
at the end by him introducing which we
think he'll introduce fully is the code
to harrison to kind of tame this inner
animal in these urges it's seeing
harrison here go full
ballistic on those urges now when i'm
talking about transitional it's kind of
just watching dexter run away from this
henchman who shoots him in the leg he's
kind of now the white deer he was kind
of hunting but the different angle now
for dexter that he's being hunted but my
favorite thing about these sequences
with him in the henchmen was the way
dexter got him in the end was by jumping
through a freaking mirror that was great
very creative clever way to get him and
i also love the nice touch here of after
dexter killing this henchman to unlock
his phone he actually uses his dead face
to unlock it i thought that was great
and just also want to bring up nice
catch by many commenters on my videos
saying how in the title sequence the new
blood part of the title is filling up
with blood more and more and if you
notice in this episode it's really close
to filling up fully now the strongest
part of this episode are the scenes to
me
with kurt and harrison
that is really an attribute to clancy
brown's performance and jack alcott's
performance as harrison i think they're
both great actors and really the mvp
this season is more and more becoming
clancy brown as he's just a treat to
watch here and seeing how invested he is
in this role and to me why the episode
was so strong with their scenes was
showing you how much they really do like
each other how
harrison really does fill that mat role
for him and vice versa that he really is
like a father figure to harrison and
it's earned really well here in their
dialogue and what's also interesting
is when they first get to this school
when harrison's looking at the trophies
of mats kurt actually slips up a bit
here and says he was special talking
about matt and saying in past tense and
that's kind of what triggers harrison to
bring up matt and where is he and you
see even harrison says people are pretty
forgiving especially during the holidays
but we know that's not kurt in this case
that even though as much as he likes
harrison he at the end of the day is got
to get his revenge on dexter for killing
his son now i just want to say you know
clancy brown definitely played baseball
growing up or still plays softball or
something because he has one hell of a
swing in that batting cage he is
slamming ropes there i mean he looks
like tony gwynn up there so it's funny
you look at his social media he's a huge
baseball fan and a reds fan so it
definitely makes sense but there's two
ways you can look at this scene you
could say oh it's brilliant or it's it's
clever it's unique with harrison taking
these hits with the balls and him
stepping closer and closer in but
there's also a part of it that's kind of
goofy and that even starts with when
harris is actually starting to hit the
ball and that smile he puts on i just
thought it was a little silly and then
yeah him getting hit by these balls you
know it was a little like okay
oh yeah yeah bring that [ __ ] on man
oh god i love it i assume
oh god that hurt a little but i'm all
right oh my god son what the hell are
you doing 364 more days till next year's
hockey trials i gotta toughen up yeah
oh god i felt good yeah but this will
set up the conversation kurt has with
harrison later at his cabin where he's
like stop punishing yourself you are you
are and you do that thing whatever
brings you pleasure in this world you
just take the leap so this is the
complete opposite of how dexter is going
to want him raise him on all this that
kurt's someone if he was his father you
know would just kind of be like just be
you embrace these violent urges no worry
for consequences in your behavior where
dexter wants to control the urges and
guide them for good the way his father
had taught him you also are wondering
more and more what the real deal is with
kurt again with these embalming of the
bodies what he's doing with them where
they are and what happened to his
deceased wife exactly what went on in
that situation i'm excited to see that
reveal now where the best writing was in
this episode was with kurt saying
sometimes a kid just ends up suffering
for the choices of his father you know
this is the whole theme of this season
and
it's the consequences of dexter's
lifestyle on his son and that he has to
face that and it was nice they threw in
a line with harrison saying how him and
his father both have abandonment issues
so again it's just building that bond
that they're going to have by the end of
this episode more and more that what
harrison can really relate to dexter on
and again going back to this father
theme and having the sins of the father
you literally have when kirk comes in
saying wish it could have worked out
differently sins of the father here it's
an f'd up world out there and this is
huge because episode 10 is literally
titled as we know the finale sins of the
father so you wonder get your theories
going but
i mean it doesn't look good for dexter
just even that being the title and
maybe also it looks worse for harrison
in a sense if you look at the title
because
he might just suffer from you know
decisions of dexter and that's
inevitable and that dexter will really
have to face that finale we'll see which
way they go with it but it's going to be
interesting and that's clearly going to
come full circle at the end but you see
kurt really wanted dexter there to watch
him kill his own son which was brutal
but dexter saves the day here and he
embraces harrison and we get this big
moment in the car ride home where he's
like you never have to feel alone with
your dark thoughts again i was born in
blood just like you same violent urges
didn't know how to deal with them but my
dad taught me a code way to channel
those urges i'm going to tell you
everything this is huge and this is what
gets harrison to hug him finally and he
finally has his father open up to him
and they can connect on these things so
you're getting that payoff that's been
set up and waiting for this moment to
happen now it might be divisive i think
there's some fans who are going to think
this is a little corny uh and that maybe
dexter would never have this line where
he's like this is all i had to do all he
ever wanted and if i'm being honest
maybe this is all i ever wanted to
that can go both ways and i could see
both arguments where it's great it's
touching and some that might not like
that and not feel that for the vibe of
this show i'm in the group that i do
like this a lot and i think
to make dexter a more human character
this had to eventually happen and again
you know people can say he's just a
serial killer doesn't feel but that's
clearly not the case and
you could even go back to the earlier
seasons with him and rita and these kids
like there's a also
not just to me that he's covering and
looking normal in real life i do think
there is something deep deep down that
wants that connection that love family
connection he never had so
yeah i think that's clearly there and
they're just exploring that and he's
growing as a character and i really like
too in this narration of dexter and this
moment in general just the piano playing
under it was a nice score not doing too
much but really adding to this weight of
the scene it closes on not a cliffhanger
but a big character moment and a thing
that's going to change everything now
having harrison and dexter kind of
getting on the same page now on the
other side of the episode what's
interesting is angela we're just
watching her like i said that feeling of
it being a transitional episode just her
catching up to everything about dexter
but what's i really like they did is
that they had her figure out a lot of
this out through the ketamine shot in
the neck on the two drug dealers and
what's huge is her now connecting even
further
dexter to being the bay harbor butcher
just scratching the surface with it but
clearly we know the final piece for her
connecting us all is going to be molly
because she has this podcast and she has
covered the bay harbor butcher and why i
really like this is they could have went
the route where
oh you know they're just figuring out
dexter and he's caught on the death of
matt but i like they're going no they're
going big picture like he's gonna get
caught on his
being this huge serial killer the bay
arbor butcher so i really like they're
going full-on here this is for just the
whole story of dexter as a whole as a
nice payoff not just this season so i'm
gonna actually give this one just on
feeling alone a 9.1 i thought it was a
really strong episode maybe not as good
as the last two but that just comes from
it having to go through kind of
transitional things like watching dexter
run through the woods and having angela
figure some things out to kind of set up
i sure some huge next two episodes
especially now that harrison and dexter
finally had the talk and that kurt's on
the run so he's also going to have to
get his closure here but i think it's
going to lean more towards the problems
now with angela and then figuring dexter
out and dexter getting caught but
obviously we're not done with kurt here
we have more to learn about these bodies
he's still going to want to kill dexter
and what the hell happened with his wife
so i think it's all just kind of hit the
fan in these two episodes and i hope in
my opinion that they do really wrap up
all the stuff in this season and not
make it let's pull this to another
season i don't mind if they make another
season i'll i'm sure i'm gonna enjoy
that they're gonna do that but that they
give us closure for the stories this
season for sure um but i'm excited
nonetheless uh let me know what you
thought down below i love to see your
comments i read every one of them and i
try to respond as many as i can please
make sure to subscribe so miss one of my
dexter